الموسم الدرامي الرمضاني هذا العام سيشهد
منافسه حاده بدات بالفعل منذ بدء عرض
البروموهات للمسلسلات والبرامج الاعمال
كثيره قصص مختلفه املا في جذب انتباه
المتابعين منصه شاهد وحدها ستعرض ما يزيد
عن 45 عملا ضربيا رمضانيا بين المصري
والسوري واللبناني والخليجي والاعمار
المشتركه منها ما هو اجتماعي وكوميدي
وبعضها كاجزاء مكمله لمسلسلات سابقه لاقت
اقبالا ونجاحا وبعضها جديد كليا بالاضافه
الى مسلسلات ال 15 حلقه المزيد حول ابرز
هذه الاعمال مع الزميله لميس ابراهيم
[موسيقى]
الجمهور متشوق لمعرفه تفاصيل اكثر وقائمه
مسلسلات رمضان 2023 التي تنوعت بين دراما
الخليجيه والمصريه والسوريه واللبنانيه
وغيرها من الاعمال
ومن اهم هذه الاعمال المصريه مسلسل تحت
الوصايه الذي استطاع ان يحدث الجدل بمجرد
عرض الملصق دعائي للمسلسل وانهارت حينها
الانتقادات على بطله المسلسل منى زكي
باعتبارها تسيء للمحجبات
احدث احداث المسلسل تدور في اطار درامي
حول سيدات تنفق على اسرتها من خلال عملها
على مركب صيد وتواجه عله الاسره العديد من
الخلافات والمشاكل التي تسعى لحلها الكبير
قوي يعود من جديد ينافس في قائمه مسلسلات
رمضان 2023 ايضا بموس به السابع هذه المره
تدور احداث المسلسل في اطار كوميدي حول
شخصيه الكبير ومواقفها مع ابناء قريه
المزاريط وتعود معه مربوحه ايضا الشخصيه
التي لاقت اعجاب الجماهير في الموسم
السابق وهو من بطوله احمد مكي رحمه احمد
فرج بيومي فؤاد هشام اسماعيل محمد سلام
حسين ابو الحجاج
دنيا مش رومانسيه
اشيل عنها شويه
عايزه اكمل الحكايه للاخر تحلوت
كلميني على المشروع عندنا مزرعه صغيره كده
[موسيقى]
في هذا الموسم الرمضاني والتي عادت بعد
غياب مسلسل
الذي يتكون من عشرين حلقه ويعتمد في كل
حلقه على حكايه جديده يعد المسلسل من اشهر
المسلسلات السعوديه والخليجيه وحتى
العربيه بدا انتاجها عام 1992 حيث تم
تقديم 18 جزء من المسلسل بسبب نجاحه غير
المسبوق عربيا وعرض الجزء رقم 18 سنه 2011
ثم توقف بعدها ليعود هذا العام تدور احداث
طاش في اطار جوني كوميدي حول عدد قضايا
ومشاكل المجتمع السعودي بشكل خاص وهو
بالطبع من بطوله ناصر القصبي عبد الله
السدحان يوسف الجراح فهد الحيان ريماس
منصور وريم عبد الله وغيرهم الكثير
انا حبيتك عشانك انت
[تصفيق]
رجعنا معاكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام
[موسيقى]
هذولا 36 سنه الله يعينك
رميه السوريه التي ينتظرها الجمهور العربي
بشغف في رمضان 2023 مسلسل مربى العز الذي
يناقش قضيه الاخلاق في المجتمع ويلقي
الضوء على التحولات الغريبه التي طرات على
منظومه القيم والاخلاق ايضا مسلسل النار
بالنار ينافس ضمن قائمه مسلسلات رمضان
2023 الذي يعرض على منصه شاهد وتدور احداث
العمل في حاره صغيره والتناول احداث موضوع
العنصريه بشكل جريء وهو من بطوله عابد فهد
كاريس بشار جورج خباز
دينامكي وتعرف تمي